did you know that the characters from
Netflix's pain Hustlers are based on
real people and did you know that it
only took Chris Evans minutes to prepare
that rap scene yes plenty went on behind
the scenes of this movie that made this
flick a bit more interesting and we've
got it all here did you know that the
entire idea for pain Hustlers was born
when director David Yates read an
article about the opioids crisis pain
Hustlers isn't exactly based on a true
story but it is an interpretation of
real events the idea came from an
article written by Evan Hughes this
article made quite an impact and as far
as Yates was concerned it was
interesting and vital fodder for a film
I read evans's article it was my
introduction to something that had been
going on for years and years in America
so it was shocking to me and it felt
immediately compelling to to craft and
build a story because of the importance
of this story the team behind Pain
Hustlers wanted to make sure that it was
done in a way that was both entertaining
and accurate we came through it through
a journalistic lens this of course meant
a lot of research our process started
with reading through thousands of pages
of Court transcripts interviewing lots
and lots of people and while the
characters were fictional they were
based on interviews from real people
making them feel a lot more real
informing the public about the opioid
crisis in a way that actually reflected
the reality of the situation still this
film goes further than that it's really
an American parable about how ambition
and greed and naivity can kind of
overrun you and take you to some pretty
dark places pain Hustlers may be based
on a real life crisis but there was
still plenty to be done in terms of
World building and creating a story for
the audience to sink its teeth into I
think it was 38 drafts of the treatment
we really wanted to make sure that the
world was brought to life in a way that
was authentic and there were a lot of
Court transcripts to go through and a
lot of research writing this film was no
small task but David Gates was confident
all along in how to create a film that
would best tell the story yates's idea
was simple and it was all about bringing
an understanding of this ongoing crisis
to the world in a way that would get
people's attention just like that
article got his the approach is to bring
as many people to the movie as possible
you know it's a it's a huge topic it's a
serious topic he was careful not to come
across too Earnest and instead have fun
with it his strategy was important and
you deliver a really sort of
exhilarating experience for the audience
and it brings people to the subject
ultimately the important story and
strategic delivery meant everything make
it fun make it entertaining but leave
them with a message Emily Blunt's
character Liza Drake is a central part
of this film and while the film is
inspired by real life Liza isn't exactly
a real person you know Liza is based on
several people uh not exclusive
exclusively related to any one of them
and and also there's a fictional element
to her as well blunt didn't just portray
Liza perfectly she had a lot to do with
creating the character and Emily got a
copy of the script she was excited by
Liza Drake's imperfection Liza's
realistic relatable and far from perfect
actions made her a unique and exciting
character one of the very first things
that she flagged was this fearlessness
of wanting to play the moral Le dark
side of this character Emily Blunt and
Chris Evans were perfectly cast in pain
Hustlers and if you've seen it you know
that these two have great chemistry on
screen is that even legal 67 and a 65
and it seems that they were a great team
off screen too blunt was even there when
Evans was voted People's sexiest man
alive and she was proud of her co-star I
think he was a bit embarrassed but sort
of secretly thrilled you know who
wouldn't be thrilled these two co-stars
are clearly great Pals we can only
imagine how hard Emily was laughing when
she first saw that rap scene Chris
evans's rap is certain certainly a
standout moment in pain Hustlers as it
turns out the cast and crew was just as
shocked to see the scene as the audience
was Chris goes and does this amazing rap
video that he had basically a few hours
to get the lyrics and the song down and
the entire room is like Chris Evans can
rap like a professional oh my God
bringing a character to life always
takes a lot of work and hair makeup and
costumes often play a major role costume
designer Colleen Atwood had her work cut
out for her when it came to making these
newly wealthy characters look well newly
wealthy I think my rule in the beginning
was was really used clothes thrift store
clothes and then as they ascended like
going up Market to like a private
Boutique or some kind of shopping like
that this definitely gave the characters
a realistic feel it was a great
experience that way for me and to
collaborate with her Chris and you know
Catherine O'Hara and everybody what did
you think of the casting for this film
did you think this story was a good way
to approach this important topic let's
talk about it in the comments and for
more videos like this one like And
subscribe to the
things